[Music]
they did surgery on a great have you
heard about this this can't be true
there is no way they did surgery on a
great let me look at my second most
reliable news source suppose we don't
get a surgery on the girl the prophecy
was true how could we have all been so
blind
this happens eight years ago really well
I thought it happened recently oh is
that the joke oh I get it
Oh before this video gets started too
much March what are you freaking doing
check out Murch Lincoln description we
got the brand new pew news merch
designed by me I love these two tees
they look very slick look at that hmmmm
we also have v lasagna merch out as well
nothing personal t serious but I need to
cash it in on this they are up today so
check out represent icon size pity pot
you don't want to be the person that
hasn't bought merged before Christmas
trust me it's going to go bad for you in
the most important manner they did
surgery on a grape they did surgery on a
grape guys they freaking did it they did
surgery baby they did surgery on a great
they did surgery on a great they did
surgery on a grape
that's literally impossible oh my
freaking gosh if Ben Shapiro is shocked
then I think we all should be pretty
shocked Tom Hanks of course is gonna
play in the Marvel adaptation as great
surgery man can't wait for that one
now that Stan Lee is the tailor said
they will never they will never do
surgery on agree but they did eight
years ago why is this a meme now stop
stop this mean was so obnoxious this is
worse than the weed flicks but okay this
is the new version of weird flicks but
okay you do understand that right you
can apply this information to literally
any context of any social interaction
hey
how do you do they did surgery on a
grape I just integrate they did did you
know did you know that they did surgery
on a grape bet you didn't know that
happen eight years ago you want to WoW
any of your friends colleagues loved
ones grapes just hit him with the fact
that they did surgery and agree but a
lot of people don't understand that
surgery does come with a risk involved
not all grapes lives
[Music]
[Applause]
no one can ever say dipping fries in
your frosty is weird again they did
surgery on a grape excuse me Wendy I
believe it's my job to kill the memes
what are you doing with that I'm the one
who does name review no one else they
did surgery on a grape whoa this is
forced oh yeah cuz all other memes are
so natural everyone just gets on board
completely not just to miss out on the
joke and not feel part of the group it's
all hey guys have you hey have you guys
seen this have you guys seen this guy's
neck now this is a natural meme no just
kidding
the neck meme gets of course surgery on
a grape what the [ __ ] did I just rate
the neck I mean what is wrong with my
brain that grape meme gets of course
they did surgery on a grape
hahahahahahaha that's a rating enjoy it
now this man's neck can we talk about we
need to talk about this man's neck my
god this Maine's neck is big this man's
neck is very large why is no one talking
about this everyone is all about they
did surgery on a grape I'm like well
this man's neck is big that's how you
reply to anyone go in with needed
surgery and a grape oh yeah have you
seen this man's neck that's goddamn
right is a big neck this man his name is
Charles Deon McDowell he was arrested in
gesek
Florida who would have thought he was
arrested in Florida never would have
guessed I swear to God some alien ship
just crashed him Florida and mutated a
bunch of people and then they that's a
bit mean and harsh to say I mean
mutation doesn't have to be bad I mean
look at this man's neck now the sheriff
posted this on Facebook and the comments
are beautiful boy boy looked like he
could drink peanut butter if he hiccup
too hard he'll swallow his whole head
why are all the comments so negative
wonder when his next court date ace
these jokes finally someone realizes
that these jokes aren't funny this is so
much brother so much uncle dad or neck
whew
dude gets sent to the guillotine and it
breaks on his neck
this man single-handedly destroyed the
French Revolution this man is the one
punch man of necks nothing can penetrate
this man nothing how he got stopped by
the police is beyond me when you do
chin-ups for a living
Charles Dion McDowell is captured his
neck is still at large
god damn his neck is big but he's not
just any name he's jolly Saint Nick he's
the father figure of Christmas Thank You
Santa Jesus Nick they did serger and a
great day that's what I'm reading this
me guys heard this song it's straight-up
fire bro why are all my favorite rappers
doing covers of this muffin song
[Music]
muffin meme gets a they did Sergey or in
a grape I didn't say anything I'm gonna
say the n-word at least there's one meme
still kicking it is the goddamn awful me
but it's sick it's still alive goddamnit
no matter how many times the third time
I've shown it it just doesn't die I
don't know what I guess I have no power
over the next me name review next meme
or whatever it is we actually have memes
this week how about that one meme
revolving my name that's right it's my
very pleasure to review this meat to
kill it once and for all I'm sick of it
this is bullying this is cyberbullying
if I had Susan's number on speed dial
which I have I will call her up and I
will say delete everyone you know what
execute article 13 sounds sick of it
it's not okay
you think I'm used to bullying you think
I'd be used being treated like a like a
laughingstock every single day no one
takes me seriously I have thoughts I
have feelings no one cares about
so this is what I get
[Music]
someone took a picture an unsolicited
image in my own spare time minding my
own business returning the cart from the
shopping center and people just
Photoshop it to make it look like the
card is taking me back or that it would
the leg swap really clever really clever
oh because I don't have legs is that why
dehumanizing you're just humanizing me I
do have legs it was a joke I swear to
God I have legs oh you're trying to rub
it in that I'm not part of Disney
anymore is that what this is LEGO
version at least I can appreciate the
aesthetic of this meat thank you very
much
oh look at that the tables have been
turned what even a state's okay see this
one makes sense because if I don't have
legs this is how I go around this is
actually the unfolded this is the
original all this mean what even is this
then it doesn't even make any freaking
sense Hey look no legs how about that
this is the unedited version of this
mean we found it finally oh my god god
dammit
[Music]
but of course like all good memes they
will find one day a peer Amin review to
see their last moment to take their last
breath and and this meme is no exception
this meme get set he did search so I was
just thinking about something else this
meme gets of course a 10 out of 10
because it involves me so it's
automatically 10 out of 10 check at the
Pew Research that's right we ship before
Christmas if you order now so it's time
it's time my fellow bros brofist
at least this one i can appreciate
[Music]